hey guys you even got the band behind
you
tap you want to know how baltimore feels
about this win we got a marching band
without you just behind us ron i can't
remember the last time i've been in a
building for a football game like that
how would you describe this one let me
tell you something i am over here
exhausted because i put so much energy
into watching this game and this is
absolutely incredible and i look at
lamar jackson and i was so proud of him
fighting and clawing and we got to give
a lot of props to that offensive line
alejandro villanuevae went from right
tackle to left tackle he did an
outstanding job
i just thought it was a great victory
and lamar needed this i mean who
deserves it more than lamar i'm right
there with you what did you think of the
way that kansas city played him
defensively kansas city's plan going up
against the bar you know they want to
run the football like this what'd you
think of their plan
i didn't i didn't really understand it
because i thought they were going to
really truly try to load the box up and
try to stop the run and they just
couldn't do it and you know if we know
um
patrick mahomes is great and he can
score a lot of points but at the end of
the day if this offense if this defense
cannot stop the run game they're going
to struggle moving forward one of the
points you continue to make to me it
wound up being a huge factor in this
game how great lamar jackson is when you
get down around the red area down around
that red zone why is he so tough to
defend from a defender's perspective you
think about it first and foremost they
have so many weapons mark andrews they
got you know wide receivers and lamar
they do and the offensive line is really
tough inside at the center in the guard
position but he's just tough man you
can't even tackle him in the open field
and then that will and that thirst to be
great
he showed it here tonight bro
from the kansas city chiefs perspective
take me from their side they had a
chance to go win this game late they're
driving down the field
edwards elaire a tough fumble how did
the ravens go punch that ball out when
they needed it that's what they're
taught and ever since i've been playing
against the ravens for 15 years in the
league and covering them the last 12 or
13 years it's been the same it it's been
the same thing them trying to be
aggressive create turnovers you saw ray
lewis out here doing all that crazy
stuff but at the end of the day i mean
watch it
everybody's at the line of scrimmage and
you know they're gonna punch they're
gonna grab and that's why
coaches love veteran running backs
because they know how to protect the
football how about the way that they
just pop up ray lewis they put him up on
the jumbotron here before the biggest
moments in this game before that final
fumble but find that before that final
forced fumble they put ray lewis up on
the jumbotron he just starts speaking to
the crowd in here he's just telling the
crowd bring it up bring it up bring it
up and they do just that this fan the
fans were insane here in baltimore
tonight what'd you think of the defense
in this game chris sims well i think
rodney you hit on it i i did not expect
the chiefs to get pushed around the way
they did you know and honestly honestly
rodney you alluded to it i thought the
chiefs really did load the box they
tried to stop the run the concerning
thing is the numbers were right they
just got pushed around and it's not only
tonight it was last week against the
cleveland browns i thought with geron
reid edition a defensive tackle chris
jones moving out to defense end this
would be a much more stout defensive
line right now i'm i'm kind of concerned
this looks like the chief's defense we
saw from three or four years ago when it
was towards the bottom of football you
know before steve spagnola got there so
i don't know how you feel about it
rodney but this is two weeks in a row
and i am a little worried about it as we
go here forward
chris it's so easy to get spoiled when
you have a great offense from a
defensive standpoint where you get lazy
because you know your offense can run a
bunch of different shootouts and i told
you
i told you since that very first
interception i said the ravens need to
run the football they just need to run
the football that's all they need to do
run the football use that set up play
action pass and throw the ball down the
field and rob before the start of the
game you laid out the ravens playing
defensively try to match up with some of
the greats travis of course tyreke hill
also travis kelsey
how'd that play and play out on the
field what did they try to do with those
two well i look at tyreek hill first and
foremost and i said put a corner on him
and keep a safety deep jamming him
making his life miserable at the line of
scrimmage that's exactly what they did
then they took the bigger they took a
bigger alignment or defensive lineman
and they kept jamming
um travis kelsey and this is how you
play them you don't let them get
anything deep when they get deep and
they make those big plays down the field
the entire team gets excited gets
ignited and it's very difficult to beat
him
and you were saying all along that andy
reid doesn't mind these shootouts he
loves them
because he feels like he has the best
quarterback on the planet he has these
weapons he's got the best tight end he's
got one of the best wide receivers he's
got a good offensive line what else does
he need and he has tyron matthew
and if he just ends up being the final
team to have the football they're going
to march down the field win the game
they march down the field you thought
that they were going to win the game it
just didn't happen ball pops out ravens
get the dub next thing you know
it was crazy man crazy tonight
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports